le conseil de défense et de sécurité
nationale qui s'est réuni ce matin sous
l'autorité du président de la république
a donc acté les décisions suivantes
nous allons lever l'obligation générale
du port du masque un extérieur
le haut conseil de santé publique nous a
adressé hier un avis sur le port du
masque en extérieur dont nous allons
tirer les conséquences sans délai le
port du max années steria heures ne sera
donc plus obligatoire sauf dans
certaines circonstances quand on se
regroupe
quand on se trouve dans un lieu bondé
une files d'attentes sur un marché ou
encore dans les tribunes d'un stade
les arrêtés préfectoraux qui régissent
le port du masque en extérieur seront
donc modifié dès demain pour traduire
cette nouvelle règle de bon sens au
regard de l'évolution de la situation
épidémique
bien sûr le port du masque restera
obligatoire dans les lieux clos
notamment au travail dans les commerces
dans les transports et dans tous lieux
de rassemblement
deuxième évolution le couvre-feu à 23
heures qui devait vous le savez
s'appliquer jusqu'au 30 juin cessera de
s'appliquer à compter de ce dimanche
soit dix jours avant la date prévue
si cette mesure de couvre feu répandait
un vrai besoin pour accompagner la fin
de la troisième vague
les très bons résultats enregistrés ne
le justifie plus du reste vous le savez
seuls trois pays dont la france
ils recouraient encore et la grèce qui
fait partie ces trois pays a également
décidé de le supprimer
cela ne signifie cependant pas que
deviendront possibles des rassemblements
sauvages festif sans respect des règles
barrière que cela se produise d'ailleurs
un début ou en fin de soi